hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2010 american science fiction and
thriller movie called the crazies
the movie takes place in the fictional
town of ogden marsh where everyone lives
peacefully and everything seems fine a
girl named becca asks her employer dr
judy dutton to go home early to watch a
baseball game which is the biggest game
in the town the game begins and
everybody has gathered in the baseball
court including sheriff david and deputy
russell
the game is surprisingly entertaining
until an old man rory randomly enters
the center field with a shotgun
david spots this and immediately runs
towards him to calm him down
the sheriff suspects that rory is drunk
but he suddenly lifts his shotgun and
aims at david
he then takes him down in front of the
spectators
that night david brings the corpse to a
pathologist called jim for autopsy he
then approaches rory's wife peggy and
his son to clarify what was happening
however peggy claims that it is
impossible that her husband was drunk
because he quit drinking two years ago
she slaps david in the face before she
walks away
since the incident david keeps feeling
guilty and his wife judy who is pregnant
calms him by saying he did the right
thing
the next day david goes to the office
and receives a call from jim who states
that there was no alcohol inside rory's
bloodstream
the sheriff insists that he was drunk
and hangs up
david is still curious and revisits the
baseball court to do a further
investigation
he meets ben who acts weird and tries to
talk to him
however ben talks nonsense and suddenly
leaves the place
on the other side judy examines a
patient bill who is also acting strange
she tells bill's wife that bill is
healthy
that evening bill's wife and son
nicholas are confused because they hear
the tractor's engine sound in the middle
of the night
she thinks bill is still working in
attempts to approach him but finds no
one
suddenly nicholas screams and she
immediately rushes back to the house
nick finds his mom and they hide inside
a closet unfortunately bill knows this
and deliberately locks the door
after that he pours gasoline all over
the house and eventually burns his own
house
a few hours later david and judy arrive
at the crime scene and learn that bill
is the only survivor judy questions bill
but he gives no response and doesn't
seem remorseful at all
the next day a group of hunters
accidentally discover a corpse in the
swamp
david russell and jim head over to the
swamp and identify the corpse
russell remembers that a week ago he
received a report about something
crashing around the swamp the two then
explore the river and find an enormous
plane sinks beneath them
russell and david go to the town
planner's office and ask kevin about
drinking water flow in the town to
determine whether it is contaminated or
not
they figure out that rory's house is the
first building to get the treated water
david immediately approaches the mayor
requesting to shut off the entire town's
water supply however the mayor
immediately rejects the request as it is
just based on a hunch and the town is
filled with farmers shutting down the
water will kill the entire crops
the sheriff insists and shuts down the
town's water supply on his own
afterwards they return to the office
only to find that bill is turned into a
zombie david tries to make a call but
all communication services are lost he
walks out but somehow everyone is gone
someone silently observes david from a
distance when he finds out the man
escapes with his car
the sheriff hears strange noises from
the funeral house
he gets inside and jim suddenly attacks
him the pathologist attempts to kill
david but he manages to fight back and
eliminate the zombie
that night david orders judy to stay
with her parents but they suddenly spot
someone is in their storehouse
he checks the storehouse but suddenly
gets confronted by a group of armed
soldiers who eventually comes to rescue
them
they are brought to the quarantine
facility where a temperature check is
mandatory before they can enter the
facility
it's judy's turn and the device suddenly
beeps so the soldiers take her away
separating her with her husband she is
taken to an isolated room
meanwhile david and uninfected citizens
are transported outside the town and are
given a bracelet david meets kevin whose
wife is brought away too
he tells him that he plans to get back
to rescue judy however kevin reveals
that the whole town has been sealed off
and everyone who tries to break in was
shot dead
not long after a red vehicle approaches
the group and the soldiers immediately
shoot down the entire passengers
the situation becomes chaotic as
everyone is running in fear in the
emerging chaos david manages to steal a
helicopter and flies back to the town
he arrives at the office and takes his
gun
suddenly russell who also managed to
escape confronts him and reveals that
judy is still safe
back to judy an infected man or a zombie
enters the isolation room and starts
slaughtering everyone just before he
impales judy david and russell come to
the rescue they release her and also
take judy's assistant becca with them
they walk towards the center of the town
and discover that everything has been
burnt down
russell checks the nearby cars and
eventually finds a pickup that is not
booted just before he enters the vehicle
suddenly a gunshot is heard and they run
away hiding behind another car
turns out that they are some weirdo
people who are shooting innocent people
ruthlessly
since they left with the car the
survivors have to walk several miles to
david's place where he keeps an old
cruiser they stop by at becca's
boyfriend's place scotty for a moment
and find out that he is still healthy
all of a sudden david hears something
and orders everyone to hide in the barn
turns out that it is the sound of the
soldiers patrolling
the soldiers break into scotty's house
and take his mother away seeing this
scottie comes out from the hideout and
runs towards them
unfortunately they shoot him to death
and immediately burn the body
a soldier attempts to check in the barn
but gets captured by david and russell
they interrogate him and the soldier
reveals that he and his unit were sent
to the town without knowing the order
and the situation
after promising them that he won't speak
up david releases the soldier and he
informs his fellow that the barn is
clear the next day they continue their
journey and eventually arrive at david's
place
lucky for them the car is still present
judy goes to a room that was previously
prepared for their baby
however a zombie is standing behind her
without her knowing that
david goes upstairs to find judy but he
is strangled from behind by the two
psychopath zombies who turn out to be
rory's wife and son seeking revenge
just before peggy shoots judy the
sheriff distracts her and uses the
opportunity to launch a counter-attack
he manages to take down the wife and
russell eliminates the sun from
downstairs
as they leave the house russell starts
showing unusual behavior but david
refuses to leave him alone
on their way they are spotted by a
passing helicopter and david quickly
drives the car into a car wash all of a
sudden the car washing machine turns on
they try to escape but the car cannot
move as he can't get any traction
several zombies approach the car and
start attacking everyone
after a rough fight they managed to
defeat the zombies and the car
eventually moves
unfortunately a zombie appears and ties
a pipe around becca's neck causing her
to be pulled out from the car
they shoot the zombie and try to help
her but it's too late to make things
worse their car is destroyed by the
helicopter
the trio continue escaping the town on
foot until they discover a car
russell spots a car emerging and spread
spike strips to stop the vehicle
they interrogate the man inside the car
he reveals that the crashed plane was
carrying a biological weapon called
trixie which was initially designed to
destabilize a population
they continue questioning the man and
find out the virus incubation period is
48 hours but russell shoots him in the
head
he gets into the car and discovers a gun
he uses it to threaten the couple and
orders them to walk in front of him
after a long walk david turns around and
attempts to talk to his deputy russell
lowers his gun and david punches him in
the face while grabbing the gun
at this point russell realizes that he
is infected but he begs to keep walking
with him
they finally arrive at the border of the
town which is fully guarded by the
soldiers the deputy sacrifices his life
to distract the soldiers so that the
couple can pass through the border
undetected
david and judy arrive at a truck stop
where they discover that all evacuated
people have been slaughtered judy
believes the soldiers will kill them too
but david still wants to give his best
effort to save his wife and baby
while the sheriff is taking necessary
stuff from the store he spots a radio
and learns that the military are going
to blow up the entire town in 10 minutes
the electricity in the store is shut
down
judy grabs a knife and is confronted by
a zombie
she runs into a room and hides there
until the zombie goes away
david eventually finds him and they get
into a truck
unfortunately the truck won't start so
david gets out and searches the driver's
body to find the right key
as soon as he reaches the key a zombie
shows up and david is pulled by another
zombie while david fights the zombie
under the truck judy manages to take
down the other ones
soon after the sheriff burns down the
zombie and retrieves the key
the couple drive away while the
countdowns begin
just after they manage to escape the
town a big explosion occurs from behind
and disables the truck they survive and
continue their journey as they head
toward another city cedar rapids by foot
they are spotted by a satellite the
satellite also shows that they are going
to initiate the containment protocol at
cedar rapids indicating that david and
judy's survival journey is still not
over subscribe to watch more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching
[Music]